I turn to my right and providing some
insight in the Honda inside a report of
what in the heck happened in staples
last night and what it means for the
Lakers today and moving forward as a man
who's been covering the Lakers for the
athletic for the past year he and his
brother Brian have the kamenetsky
brothers podcast he also is a radio host
here locally in Los Angeles and hosts
the pre and post game for the Laker
broadcast good to see you Andy
kamenetsky great to be back what
happened last night everyone is still
trying to figure that out late last
night just to set the stage Luke Walton
was doing his pregame press conference
you know just the normal stuff and
everybody was thinking about okay is
this going to be Luke's
last day doing this and Luke even
acknowledged that narrative and you know
he's been asked about this a lot and
made a joke about you know asked me
tonight after the game if I'm still
nervous about my job security then all
of a sudden Magic Johnson appears out of
nowhere tells one of the people from
Lakers PR that he wants to do a press
conference I thought he was joking I
gather he's just messing around because
there's all this media then all of a
sudden he gets behind the podium like oh
he's actually doing a press conference
what's he gonna talk about and he cut to
the chase pretty quickly that he was
stepping down and as magic as want to do
he talked and talked and talked and I
mean I think I could have ridden home
shotgun with him if I just asked I mean
he just was talking to anybody who would
listen it was crazy
so um let me get let's get to the heart
of the matter why did he do it this way
I know he said that he didn't want to
tell Jeannie buss his sister who's like
a sister to him to her face but then he
waited to tell her after he told the
media maybe it's it easier for him to
tell her once the cats completely out of
the bag the Lakers and E are our
franchise that's put together everything
is manicured it's like the best lawn
that's in front of the most beautiful
house that's filled with the greatest
artwork that's what the Lakers are and
this was a total holy heck of a mess
that's being run off the top of a head
by a guy who is just running at the
mouth who happens to be their most
famous perhaps most popular player who's
quitting at the most crucial point after
a disaster of a season and why would he
do it this way I mean first of all it's
important to note that the manicured
lawn appearance that hasn't been there
for a while and you know it's something
that the organization is always really
focused on the idea of putting out that
type of brand but the reality is it's
been largely chaos since dr. buses death
and this is the sixth straight season of
missing the playoffs so there's been a
lot of very well known dysfunction but
the idea of magic doing it this way I
mean I think he was truthful in the way
that he said it was just gonna be too
difficult for him to you know have this
conversation first with Jeanie but the
irony of that is is magic there was
always this narrative that you know he's
the ultimate closer and if you get in a
room with him it's gonna be impossible
to say no you know there was this idea
that Paul George didn't give the Lakers
a meeting because once he got in a room
with magic it would've been impossible
to say no to him then he would have had
to explain to the Thunder that he was
going back on what he said
the irony is magic couldn't get in a
room with Cheney like it the whole thing
just gets inverted on its head yeah it
just leaves you scratching head
wondering if there's something something
else some other there there especially
when today in the exit interviews nobody
who is a I guess main character in this
drama is available to talk what was it
like down the road
I mean LeBron was supposed to be doing
what would have been his equivalent of
an exit interview during the time that
magic spoke but again that threw
everybody for a loop so you were going
into last night expecting to have Magic
Johnson and polenka talk together with
LeBron at the same time and an exit
interview no I today what I was
expecting was LeBron to talk to us
yesterday in lieu of doing an exit
interview today right and then have
magic and Rob speak with us just like
they did last year and just like any
functional organization does their exit
interviews right and then this is all
totally what was it was it like a morgue
over there it's still surreal like
everyone is still just trying to ingest
what happened and I mean there is still
a lot to wrap your head around and the
organization isn't putting Luke Walton
or
polenka or any I guess adult in the room
in front of anybody
for today's exit interviews and on one
hand at some point an adult in the room
needs to speak but I can understand why
they wouldn't do it today be there is
still a lot to figure out so then let's
figure it out Andy kamenetsky here in
the Honda insider report does does this
mean that Luke keeps his gig I don't
know I mean because on one hand Magic
Johnson
very transparently has wanted to fire
Luke and me he basically said as much
yesterday and that was a source of
conflict between him and Jeanie buss hmm
so on one hand maybe that secures Luke's
safety but the flip side of it is Jeanie
has allowed Luke Walton to twist in the
wind all year like she's allowed the
perception of Luke being on the hot seat
and Luke being on the way out all year
even if her preference was to keep him
so whoever placed replaces Magic Johnson
if that guy wants to go in a different
direction with coach I would figure that
Jeanie would allow it because according
to magic and largely the reporting
that's out there magic had the
permission to drop the hammer if he
wanted to he just didn't want to once he
had actually had the opportunity to do
it even though it was clear all season
long that's what he wanted to do now
moments before you walked in here Andy
Ramona Shelburne is reporting what right
now Chris Brockman Rob blinka likely to
keep his job remain with the team might
even see his role expand in magic sleeve
does that make sense to you well there's
a lot of sawing out of it I don't think
it makes sense in the idea to Matt that
magic alluded to yesterday Rob pálinka
is not popular around the league you
know he made a lot of enemies around the
league you know as an agent you know
that often happens with agents they're
often in adversarial positions with
organizations but Rob doesn't have the
greatest reputation around the league
fair or not and I feel like all you know
preemptively keeping palinka in place
can limit your options in terms of who
you bring in to replace magic because I
don't know
if that many of the best people are
gonna want to work with Rob polenka I
mean I could be wrong unless the person
who replaces magic is Kobe Bryant and I
know that that that that so many people
are waiting for some sort of knight in
shining armor come down from the Mount
and save the lake I don't think that's
gonna happen because Kobe's too busy
winning Oscars inviting best-selling
books I would agree with you on them but
if if that were to be the case they've
learned nothing from this they've
learned absolutely no what do you mean
by that because would due respect to
Magic Johnson he didn't make sense for
this job in the first well cuz he didn't
want to do it Andy and that's the whole
thing is that if Kobe does this job on
again this is total specula I mean
beyond the exhibition cuz I don't think
it's possible I don't - when I
interviewed Kobe last year and I asked
him about what projects if who pitches
him he goes people won't pitch me I
choose the project as a matter of fact I
know what I'm doing two three four years
now like he's got it all mapped out he
knows what he's gonna be releasing in
spring of 2021 whether it's a book or a
podcast or a movie or a TV show Kobe Inc
is like a real thing right it is a real
thing and that's what he's focused on
and that's what he wants to do but this
is now being dropped out there and again
if I don't want I think in all honesty
with respect to everybody saying that
they she hasn't that then Jeanie buss
wouldn't have learned from any of this
by bringing Kobe disrespects Kobe
because Kobe if he does it would come in
with that mentality of like I am gonna
torch this place and I don't care about
your feelings I'm gonna I'm gonna do
things best for the for the team and
clearly but he's still caught magic
didn't have that Jan maybe but I mean a
lot of respect for Kobe he obviously is
gonna understand the game better than I
will right he's he's not immediately
qualified for the job that's not that is
true is like ask yourself this would any
other organization hire Kobe straight
out of the gate to do this job the
answer is likely no because he has no
experience in it correct and nobody else
I think would have hired magic to do
this job that's obvious I mean because
again it's just so stunning that
somebody would just spill out their guts
the
way that magic did and in an in a way
not only that is so jarring right Andy
Andy kamenetsky here on the Rich Eisen
show in the Honda Insight a report but
also just putting out on display
how uniquely unqualified he was for this
you know thing though if you remember I
guess it's two-and-a-half years ago when
it was announced that magic was taking
this job it was clear he thought it was
gonna be easy
or if nothing else he put out the
appearance of I got this and I gotta
learn a little about the salary cap got
to learn a little bit about the inner
workings of running a front office but I
know scouting I know players
I know winning this isn't gonna be hard
the job that he just left is brutal like
it is a brutal job I mean forget just
doing it for the Lakers you do it for
the Memphis Grizzlies you do it for any
team around the league lowest profile
it's a brutal job it is a 24/7 job
minimum and I think magic underestimated
a lot of what it takes to do this job
well but I also think Jeannie bus and
this one I'm getting at when I would say
nobody learn anything from it if you
brought in Kobe which isn't gonna happen
breast as the hypothetical yes I think
Jeannie will be under estimating and not
learning from just how difficult this
job is and the value of experience
particularly when Rob palinka is still
learning what he's doing a couple more
minutes left here on the Rich Eisen show
and magic talked about he couldn't he
didn't like the backstabbing her back
body was he referring anybody in the
Lakers organization I mean he he said
that he was talking more around the
league and you know the way it would
appear like nobody wants the Lakers to
succeed and you know the back-and-forth
between them and the pelicans he also at
the same time was given a lot of
opportunity to praise Rob polenka and he
he did not oh no he did not he very much
politely declined well I think he just
wants to get out of the out of you know
when in this seven kingdoms he wanted to
get out of King's Landing you know he
was all Game of Thrones he just wants to
get out of the game of Thrones here in
the NBA and then and tweet well he wants
to freely tweet I know that and it makes
it sound like he wants to just sit down
like like a twelve-year-old and just
want to live on Twitter he just he just
doesn't want to be an executive he
doesn't want anything to do with that he
wants to be him he wants to be magic let
me be part of it his all
wanting to entertain I mean the truth is
the idea that you could congratulate
Dwayne Wade or congratulate Russell
Westbrook do that by a text and get away
you're not gonna get exactly just what
he wants to be able to do it publicly
like the showman likes not jig that's
why there's something inexplicable
that's something there's something
missing here that we don't know as far
as I'm concerned but we'll see what that
means what that is
what's LeBrons role in all of this it
does he have a role in any of the I
think he needs to know I mean that
brought this on oh oh I I don't believe
so
I mean that certainly isn't anything
that I'm hearing and you know he and
rich Paul met with magic a few days ago
so what's he thinking right now cuz I
mean this is an absolute dumpster fire
that that that does not even equate in
many ways frequently with what even had
in Cleveland okay so he's now with two
years plus one left in his contract he's
34 he's coming off of a season with his
worst injury he's ever had this team was
a total disappointment he is you know
obviously in a town where he's
conducting his business what is he
thinking this morning well I mean there
there's got to be a part of be careful
what you wish for I mean in terms of
what he ended up signing up for and
where things are headed one thing I
think LeBron needs to be thinking is
I've got to be a big part of what comes
next
and not in a power grab type way but in
terms of making the organization seem
appealing to whoever would replace Magic
Johnson or the free agents you know
whatever free agents they pitch even if
say they managed to bring in somebody
great to replace magic and if say Luke
gets replace n Doug ooh and all their
credentials are fantastic you still have
no idea how this is going to operate you
have no idea how the Lakers are going to
function moving forward the only thing
you know is LeBron
LeBron is the one established given so I
think it's really important that he put
himself out there in this process yeah
but in a way that's really appealing as
opposed to just asserting your power for
the sake of asserting your power ask the
poll question of Andy as we send them
out the door in two crazy Los Angeles
who's the next Laker who should go rob
Palenque Luke Walton LeBron no
the above i should go d me like they
should opt to leave or we'll be told
leave told to leave is I think that the
the sense here told needs to go
LeBron could be trade right now it feels
like they all are oh if I feel like it
they have their senses right um if I had
to guess and this is purely a guess I'm
gonna say Luke only in that
LeBron's not going anywhere Rob pálinka
I you know you're hearing this reporting
that his role may expand so that would
leave by subtraction Luke again I've
know at this point we've all learned
nobody knows anything so I have no idea
what's gonna happen with them but by
process of elimination it feels like
Luke well they're finishing they're
finished with their exit interviews and
now they can there there's no media
obligations that they have to talk we're
assuming that they will eventually talk
prior to the draft in a usual setting
after maybe they they announce his
replacement and figure everything out so
they're they're hunkered down and it is
amazing it's Game of Thrones with this
is exactly what has just happened with
one of the most famous franchises in all
of North American sports I don't watch
the show as this winter is coming it is
actually winter was not coming but but
magic made it snow I mean basically is
what happened it's crazy
good to see here thanks very much thank
you for more of the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app